ever since razer announced the blade
studio i've been excited since we'll
finally have an ultra premium powerful
Windows laptop focused on professionals
finally something to go head-to-head
with Apple but taking what is good and
then also improving on what's not but
after getting to use it and test it the
blade falls short in four different ways
which I'll talk about throughout this
video there's also a lot of good and for
one particular group of people this
machine will be a godsend
but for others like photo and video
editors I have an alternative Windows
laptop with the same olá display that
will save you over $1,000 I love the
design it's an all aluminum chassis
coming in at a fairly lightweight 4.8
pounds and it's very rigid with aluminum
that doesn't feel cheap like on some
other laptops
I am glad also that Razer made their
logo nice and subtle for this pro
machine the charging port looks like USB
type-c but it's much larger and has a
really tight fit next to that we have a
headphone jack and two USB type 8 ports
that run a full 10 gigabit per second
speeds but that's not all we have
another one on the right-hand side next
to a DisplayPort output HDMI and a
single Thunder both three port I really
don't get why we only have one Thunder
both three port entry-level Windows
laptops are now starting to ship with
two so I think that this is a huge
mistake with a pro machine on the plus
side we do have an SD card reader that
supports ultra-fast UHS type 3 cards
that aren't even available yet but once
they're out those will be able to
transfer it out over 600 megabytes per
second on the inside there's another
feature that my MacBook lacks that is
Wi-Fi 6 so if you have a new router
you'll get faster speeds and better
range the battery is 80 watt hours
better than some of other razors laptops
but about 20% smaller than an XPS 15 or
a MacBook Pro because of this battery
life suffers you can expect about five
hours for lighter tasks whereas the
MacBook gets over 10 hours and for heavy
use like video editing about an hour and
a half compared to over three one
culprit is the gorgeous 4k olla display
it has to push 40
more pixels than the MacBooks 3k screen
and even though OLED could be power
efficient with lower brightness and some
of the pixels turned off when you max it
out it actually draws more power than an
LCD it's also a touchscreen if you care
for that and it has DCI p3 color
accuracy like the Mac but there's a big
caveat to that and I'll cover that a bit
later the chin bezel is quite large
since the 15.6 inch display is sixteen
by nine resulting in about ten percent
less usable workspace compared to a 16
inch 16 by 10 and we miss out on a
fingerprint reader but I absolutely love
the Windows hello login which is so
convenient that I want every laptop to
have it I have one huge issue with the
display and that's reflectivity I love
the fact that it's glossy for sharpness
but even and moderately lit rooms this
gets annoying and even with the screen
maxed out at 400 nits the pure dark
pixel benefits of OLED are gone because
blacks turn gray unless you're doing
most of your work in a dark room a
brighter LCD would have done a better
job the trackpad is surprisingly good
and it's a huge jump forward from the
last razor that I owned
unfortunately the keyboard is really mad
I had to type slower since the keys are
not only fairly shallow but also mushy
which resulted in poor typing accuracy
on the sides is my biggest
disappointment and that's the speakers
[Music]
[Music]
Razer keeps being notorious for poor
speakers and I really hope that they
would step it up on this Pro machine but
instead my iPhone is not only louder but
also sounds better in every way this is
a webcam and microphone quality test
with the Razer Blade 15 studio Edition
this is a webcam and microphone test
with a 16 inch MacBook Pro all right
enough with the negatives let's touch on
what makes this laptop special and
that's the Nvidia r-tx Quadro 5000 razor
doesn't specify it but it is the max
cube version that is rated for 90 watts
of power we have 16 gigabytes of memory
in 3072 quarter cores more than a 20 80
max Q which results in about 35% higher
T flat performance running blenders GPU
benchmark with the classic BMW and
classroom scenes took just 5 minutes and
24 seconds which is just crazy for a
laptop beating out a Vegas 64 and
nearing AMD's current best you've grown
graphics are they could buy which is the
Radeon 7 and both of these will use more
than 250 watts of power instead of just
90 the same thing goes for Unigine
heaven which tests gaming performance
using an extreme preset we got an
average frame rate of 126 believe it or
not that beats out our Mac Pro Vega twos
a hundred and twelve frames per second
that is until we unplug the razor blade
and it no longer has access to 230 watts
of wall power and has to rely on the
battery where the FPS drops from 126
down to 35 almost four times slower than
before and now slower the 'no dell XPS
15 on battery yes we did check all of
the power savings options and found that
razer literally won't let you get out of
balance power mode if you're on battery
just let has it set to medium now other
brands will but the performance will
still go down although some other
laptops will not go down as much as this
one through the blender benchmark and
now it takes 22 and a half minutes
were four times as long and in Geekbench
5s GPU test the score also drops to
about a third on battery now not
everybody needs to be portable so if
you're someone that needs a massively
powerful GPU and you have a wall outlet
everywhere you go you'll be able to make
full use of that Quadro for video
editing if you're doing something very
graphics intensive like exporting Canon
or raw footage in DaVinci Resolve it
will be twice as fast as the best
MacBook Pro but on battery it's twice as
slow a similar thing goes for actual
timeline performance where it can handle
38 frames per second instead of 32 but
unplugged that results in an unusable 13
frames per second now one thing that I
haven't touched on yet is the CPU and
this is where razor made an odd choice
the only option is a 2.6 gigahertz six
core i7 nine Chen and that's a fine
choice for tasks that are mostly GPU
heavy like gaming 3d rendering or apps
like DaVinci Resolve but in other tasks
like photo editing or Premiere Pro that
decision could be a bad one premiere is
very CPU heavy so with that same project
where the razor was twice as fast it's
no longer the case with it being 25%
slower when plugged in and almost twice
as slow on battery for these tasks that
six core CPU is really bada lacking the
graphics card in fact the most GPU usage
that I saw was 28% in Premiere Pro now I
don't want to keep hammering the same
nail here so if you want to see a huge
suite of video editing tasks that
include Final Cut Pro check out my other
video which a link in the video
description for photo editing graphics
makes little difference in what you
mainly need is CPU power so here the six
core is also limiting the performance
because of this if you're somebody that
wants a machine that could be useful for
a wide variety of tasks especially if
you're a photo editor or a use premiere
I would avoid this machine the same
thing goes for those that want to be
able to work without being plugged into
an outlet not only is the battery life
port but also the performance on battery
power as well for those I would highly
suggest getting the Dell XPS 15 which
does have a much weaker graphics card
but one that
throughout all much on battery and the
battery itself is 20% larger the
keyboard speakers and the CPU are better
and the display is the same OLED panel
as well I'll link the $2,600 option in
the description that matches the same
RAM and SSD while having an eye 9 8 core
processor now let's touch on that OLED
display if you're somebody that needs
color accuracy you have to get a display
calibrator and then make sure you
calibrate it at 2 clicks below maximum
brightness because the top levels aren't
capable of the best color accuracy once
you've done that make sure to always use
that brightness setting when you're
doing color critical work because unlike
LCDs this OLED panel shifts colors
really easily when you change brightness
if you're somebody that needs a pro
laptop with the best possible graphics
when working plugged in there is no
doubt that this is a super capable
machine and when you're not pushing the
graphics to the limits it runs fairly
quiet due to that 6 core CPU and nice
cooling design but for most other people
I would look elsewhere especially
considering the price thank you guys for
watching if you like this video click up
there to subscribe and check out our
side-by-side comparison with the MacBook
Pro or the very detailed video editing
vid right over there there's been max
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]